[Music]
big claws gnarly horns blood guts lion
vs lion elephant vs. elephant a
ferocious conflict that usually ends in
death for one or both of the individuals
involved that's how we think most animal
fights go down in the wild but the
reality is that features array of
weapons and conflicts are much more
varied sometimes what appear to be
deadly altercations or actually just
tests of strength when members of the
same species clash in the wild over
resources or a prospective mate it
doesn't always go down how you think it
will first off to the death isn't the
only option backing off can be the
smarter move B blitz sea anemones
sometimes escalate a situation or
sometimes they don't observe as a sea
anemone inflates its stinging tentacles
at a neighbor until it decides enough is
enough
it's more exciting if you speed it up
achieving victory doesn't require blood
a Caribbean rock mantis shrimp uses
club-like appendages to bludgeon an
opponent in the backside luckily the
shrimp's rump is also equipped with a
shield eventually someone gives up the
prize a burrow in a laboratory tank
[Music]
sometimes animals just need to knock the
other guy off his game rhinoceros
beetles look scary but rarely inflict
serious damage on a hot muggy night in
Taiwan males vie for a female's
attention on God using two-pronged horns
competitors fling each other from
branches the Falls aren't fatal but to
the victor go the spoils
finally ruthless killers are rare but
they can be scarier than they look these
members of a species of nematode worms
resemble dueling spaghetti noodles when
they wrestle but never go in against a
nematode when death is on the line given
the right grip they'll squeeze an
opponent's body until paralysis ensues
the loser slowly expires from internal
injuries in the animal kingdom it's not
always you win or you die but when it is
the arena is often tiny and the
conditions are cutthroat
[Music]
you